on avait là un résultat qui dépassait je
crois nos espérances 27 novembre 2005
isabelle dinoire et la première patiente
au monde à bénéficier d'une greffe
partielle du visage
défigurée par son chien en mai 2005 elle
reste six mois sans pouvoir se nourrir
normalement ni s'exprimer
l'intervention dure 15 heures elle est
réalisée par l'équipe du professeur
bernard devauchelle en collaboration
avec celle du professeur jean michel
dubernard donne et c'est un succès la
surprise a été importante en fin
d'intervention chirurgicale
je veux dire la bonne surprise tant il y
avait une parfaite congruence des
fragments une prouesse médicale certes
mais comment vivre avec le nez la bouche
et la peau d'une personne décédée à
l'époque dans la rue cette question
inquiète
ça doit être très difficile d'être
l'accepter après il ya le côté
psychologique ou la personne peut le
rocher aussi de ce côté-là je sais pas
si moi je me sentirais bien avec le
visage de quelqu'un d'autre avec une
partie visage de quelqu'un d'autre
pourtant l'équipe médicale se veut
rassurante nous avons fait un progrès
absolument considérable le problème
psychologique
petit à petit d'accepter cette nouvelle
forme de visage mais qui sera pas si
différente que ça puisque on a gardé
l'infrastructure squelettiques
certains psychologues et alerte les
conséquences d'une greffe du visage sont
alors complètement inconnu le visage la
face c'est l'identité de la personne
donc il va y avoir du point de vue
psychologique une inquiétude quant aux
glissements de son identité à soit vers
l'identité du donneur
trois mois après l'opération le 6
février 2006 isabelle dinoire s'exprime
publiquement pour la première et unique
fois perché le genre de l'opération j'ai
un visage comme tout le monde
maintenant je fais au genre larouche et
1 chez le ch tce 100 et leur on est à
gauche
novembre 2006 pour le premier
anniversaire de la greffe
le médecin se félicite de ces progrès
spectaculaires elle a fait en termes de
motricité des ddd progrès absolument
considérer ce qui fait que aujourd'hui
quand les contenter qu'elle sourit c'est
un vrai sourire quand on voit sur son
visage
affaibli par les traitements anti rejet
isabelle dinoire meurt d'un concert en
2016 onze ans après sa greffe
cette greffe partielle du visage a
ouvert le champ à d'autres interventions
encore plus spectaculaire en juillet
2010 la première greffe intégrale du
visage a été réalisée à créteil sur un
homme de 35 ans défiguré par une maladie
génétique
[Musique]